[Music]
thank you
welcome to wisdom for life where we sit
through philosophy to find practical
advice that you can use in your everyday
life hi I'm Dan Hayes and I'm joined by
my co-host Dr Greg Sadler today we're
talking about
ai's large language models and
intelligence and this is something that
we've been kind of kicking around for
quite a while because both Dan and I
like I I could say I like puttering Dan
more playing because he knows what he's
doing perhaps
and a bit more than most yeah and so
this is uh you know it's a topic I
constantly get asked about and
for me as an academic there's a lot of
Doom and Gloom about how chant GPT or
pick whatever else you want barred you
know artificial intelligence in general
is going to put us all out of jobs and
make it impossible for us to tell when
students are cheating
I don't myself have such a pessimistic
Viewpoint at it but I'm constantly
getting asked about it by people both
within and outside of the academy and
I'm actually kind of curious Dan are you
you know as a tech person are you
getting lots of people
buttonholing you and saying what do you
think about this sort of stuff
uh a little bit
um I'm more interested in the the people
that are asking about like you know what
jobs are going to go away yeah that's
the questions I'm more interested in and
it's definitely going to create a whole
new set of jobs it's going to probably
automate away other jobs
um
it's especially like very clerical based
ones but um yeah it's uh I guess as
Steve Jobs many years ago talked about
like the computer being a uh the bicycle
for the Mind where yeah
the human is kind of middle of the pack
and it's like movement to calories like
how much it can move or Traverse the
landscape versus calories whereas the
Condor is is the king of all of them
um unless you put a human on a bicycle
and now the bite of the human on a
bicycle can Traverse further distances
with less calories than the Condor it
because it makes also the the most
efficient animal out there so that's an
interesting humanocentric way of looking
at it and I think that's part of what's
often missing in these conversations
that people are so worried about
replacement right the AI is going to
mimic human beings and take over their
slots and there's you know there's not
enough attention paid to the fact that
if you want to use AI to say cheat on
essays or tests like that you need a
human who's actually going to give the
prompts and you know turn the stuff in
you know maybe maybe humans will in some
cases be just glorified button pushers
like George Jetson we remember that
cartoon where his entire job was just
pushing one button but I think that a
lot there's going to be a lot more
integration with uh between human beings
and Ai and it's going to serve you know
human purposes right
right we're going to create more and
more tools that help us actually achieve
the goals that we want unfortunately not
of all of our goals are like pro-social
that's true yeah so
um hopefully we can create some
boundaries or some rules for us to
follow in order to try to curtail the
more negative portions of this
technology yeah so we should start out
by talking about one of the things I'll
I'll put it to you this way one of the
things I wanted to stress at the very
beginning is that when we talk about
artificial intelligence or machine
learning we're really using metaphors
more than anything else
so I recently worked my way through Dan
Simmons Hyperion candles this really
great but pretty dense and quite
imaginative science fiction four-part
series each of the books of which top at
least 500 pages or so so it's quite a
read but there there's all these AIS in
it because it's set in the future and
the AIS have become you know uh
genuinely intelligent he he actually
prefers this term autonomous
intelligence instead of artificial
intelligence and he says you know we
human beings we're machines too we're
meat machines and the key thing is not
whether it can say imitate a human being
or replace a human being the key thing
is whether it can develop to the point
where it actually does the things that
we say intelligent things do right so
you know it's very behavioral view of it
uh well he yeah I mean he's not a
behaviorist or a functionalist in that
that sense he he thinks at least in his
future and he and it's funny too because
Simmons an interview after interview
people will ask him about artificial
intelligence and he'll say we're nowhere
near it I mean we're at least 50 years
away from anything that would look
remotely like what I'm doing in my my
books you know
um so you know you you had some some
stuff that you wanted to say about these
uh these metaphors I've
um I've studied the history of AI I've
written quite a bit of things that would
fall under the AI umbrella and have been
working on in and around
um AI both Visual and natural language
for the last you know decade or so and
so one of the things that we Define when
we're talking about what AI is at least
in a computer science sense is
artificial intelligence is not using the
idea of intelligence as the regular
parlance that yeah I would use in
regular everyday conversation like
hopefully our radio show is intelligent
you know yeah discourse right right
um but that doesn't mean it has
Consciousness and can come up to
individual thoughts and that's not what
artificial intelligence in the computer
science
um area also refers to an in AI all that
means that you have to have for it to be
under the the
umbrella of AI as an agent that uh can
somehow Traverse an environment on and
the environment and the intelligence
um
thus has to make decisions based off of
its internal representation of the
environment that's it's going through
okay as well as why they can sense
around the environment at that in
individual moment and so this can be as
simple as you know on
if it sees uh what I say purple in front
of it take a left if it sees yellow take
a right and if it sees nothing then go
straight or you'll so even if a simpler
the the regular algorithm that one does
that are trying to go through a
um a maze like a hedge maze is a left
hand rule just any time that you come to
an intersection take a left and
eventually you'll solve the thing or get
stuck yeah yeah I mean you know I think
there's there's two things that I I
wanted to say one one is you know when
you're talking about this sort of your
own longevity in studying Ai and then of
course you know there's things going
further back we could think about you
know is Eliza that old program that was
written originally in basic to simulate
a therapist it would basically like
regurgitate strings back to you and then
say what do you think about that
um you know that was put forward as as
something like an AI well it is under
the computer science okay terminology
for it so because the point that I was
going to make is that I think a lot of
the people who are kind of in a tizzy
about this are forgetting that AIS have
been around for quite a long time you
know they look at
um the the visual ones and they're
worried about what that's going to do to
Art and then they look at things like
these large language models with chat
GPT and Bard and Bing and stuff like
that and it's as if they they don't
recognize that you know every one of our
personal assistants that we have on our
phones is an AI right and we've we've
been using primitive AIS for a long time
for a lot of different things you know
people are being not necessarily put out
of work due to them although I've heard
um you know not just a Radiologists
worrying about that but people like
Insurance actuaries who are concerned
about that and they've been used to you
know search legal databases so the
second thing I want to ask about so this
this notion of environment right
the example that you gave like working
through a maze you've got an external
environment right but what is the
environment for say these personal
assistants like Siri or cortata is it
just the internet is the environment in
that case and they're like scouring
around trying to find you the
information that you're looking for
um to respond to your your queries is
that it depends okay on each individual
AI
um
they the large language models that we
have are pre-trained with certain
information that's the idea they're a
very large language models yeah
and so they will
um from their internal information can
regurgitate stuff out to you and so
they're not actually interacting with
any environment except for you putting
in text so in that case the environment
is only you putting in so here's the
answer yes okay
um and then
um then there are the abilities to
potentially connect this to you know
regular Google search or something and
then they would be able to potentially
use that as an extra external
environment for it to search through and
pull back information uh depending on
how sophisticated it can actually do
that okay
so when we talk about
um you know machine learning
um that's a metaphor as well right and
there's many different kinds of learning
and people talk about neural networks
and you know training P training things
on that
um is there really in a let's call it a
a human based sense is there really like
training or learning going on or is is
that just a word that we use for these
interesting processes that generate lots
and lots of cool results
so um neural networks are actually
originally based on a simplified model
of neurons in their interconnections
yeah so we have neurons in our brains
and they have axon and axons and
dendrites and those connect together
between each individual and um we learn
in part by strengthening the connections
between individual neurons and
um
weakening the connection between others
um and this is a the very similar model
to how
um
the large neural networks of which the
large language models are in themselves
neural networks
um and so we provide them a lot of
information and then we say like here's
your your correct answer or not and this
is called on supervised learning and or
you say like
um here is some a marker of
um winning or losing or progressing or
moving away from whatever your goal is
and I want you to go towards the goal
um and so it that this is what we call
unsupervised learning so it can go
um
like play a Donkey Kong yeah yeah or
sorry yeah yeah Donkey Kong um on on you
know the Atari and whatnot it's got a
little score in the top corner and it
knows that has to make that number go up
and so we'll try all these things over
and over and over again and figure out
what gets that number to go up and up
and up without any
human saying you're doing it right or
wrong yeah yeah and so these are the two
main ways we talk about training models
but it is a
um an apt analogy when we talk about
training or learning because it is using
a very similar process to how our neural
networks work within you know biological
systems they are simplified
um yeah although it's like they're
becoming more and more large it seems
like we in much of the learning that we
do it's not
long-term iterative processes doing you
know things over and over again it's
like maybe getting one or two shots at
it and then we move on to the next thing
you know ah but here's what exactly is
happening because we we start off with
like
untrained neurons right okay
children Babble before they start to
form uh actual intentional phonemes and
then they turn those into uh words yeah
and I could just look at that level yeah
uh and so what happens is when you get
these large models that are already
pre-trained what we do is we call
transfer learning we take a uh an all
really already built model that is for
something specific usually say like
um I have a model that can detect images
of like cars and trucks and whatnot but
I want to be able to detect specifically
Fords okay and so I would take this one
that's already determined it's already
knows cars and trucks yeah and other
vehicles that go on the road really well
and I said okay I'm going to feed you
some information that says this is what
Fords look like and so it takes much
less information for it to now go to
distinguish Forge as Ford trucks or cars
versus anything else and so the amount
of information or iterations that you
need to have it determined for trucks is
significantly less than if you're going
to start off from a very blank site okay
so when I first started playing around
with things that were
um
long long ago predecessors of particles
well uh we called them nonsense
generators and that was back in the late
80s early 90s and we would do things
like take you know Marx's Communist
Manifesto and feed it in and all it
would do was you know that's that's its
data set and what it would do is it
would look for like the combination of
uh letters that should follow each other
and it'd build up this big data set and
be like well you know this word should
typically follow this word and it would
spit out something that was mark C you
know but it was not Marx as such and
then we could do this with other stuff
as well and the friend the friend of
mine who was very interested in this who
started his own computer company he was
like ah we could do this with music we
could do this with whatever we want to
you know is what's going on with these
large language models you still using
something like that looking for the
patterns of how things are associated
aided with each other and then you know
spitting out things that are along those
lines like when we ask chat GPT make a
poem that's like Shakespeare it's
tapping into what it knows of
Shakespeare's sonnets for example and
that it regurgitates something that's
Shakespeare but not Shakespearean right
it's an iambic pentameter and actually
has a the correct rhyming scheme and
whatnot yeah it's quite good and some of
the same vocabulary too right yeah right
absolutely and um and it's quite good at
mimicking these things
um and what the difference here is like
you know what you're describing I I
believe are Markov chains is what we
call the data structure
um and yes that they will absolutely
kind of like they say like okay well
um given the inputs there's uh you know
uh 82 percent chance that this word
um
proceeds after this word yeah and so
it's gonna like just you know build
things until it goes to something but it
has very little ability to understand if
that actually makes a sensical sentence
yeah
um but the the thing is with at least
with markup chains you can look at them
and you can look at the exact weights
between the different words and you can
say oh that's that's weird why is it
think that like um I don't know on
tapioca should be the next word after
love
um from I don't know because it's been
listening to that band tapioca love with
the title track tapioca love on the
first album tapioca love way way too
often right
um but within well large language models
or anything that we're talking about
when we're talking about machine
learning which uses neural networks
um we don't have the ability to go and
look at how these uh inferences are
directly related to each other okay um
it's this is kind of like this thing
that's you know uh so that's why I see
it it seems kind of it's a black box
maybe a little magical to some people or
uh they they attribute personality to it
when it doesn't really have it
yeah and this comes down to the the
basic issue with
um Consciousness that with is the hard
question of Consciousness which is you
know a long-standing question philosophy
of how do you define consciousness where
is it how does it how does it arise yeah
um and and do we know that uh
Consciousness on or on you know sapience
if you're going to go to intelligence
um Can arise out of these types of you
know computer models yeah combinations
of essentially circuitry right
right although they are built in a way
to resemble neurons
so I know you wanted to talk about the
Turing test
um yes I mean is that still relevant in
yes okay absolutely suggesting that
maybe it isn't but uh well okay it is
is in one area because when we're
talking about the Turing test he's he
says it's in it's meaningless to uh this
rival discussion about the intelligences
of your programs okay
um because at least for the Practical
use of them
it is not if it is intelligence but if
it can imitate enough to be intelligent
and thus becomes a useful tool that can
actually move and interact in the world
around us so I think for some of our
listeners you probably have to explain
how the Turing test was originally set
up how it was conceived
so the Turing test is a behavioral test
and it's often done via text between two
people on two computers you have on
someone that goes up and they say um you
are going to have a conversation with
someone else on the other end of this
computer you have to determine if you
think that that person is an actual
human or a actual computer and so it's
like it's a a blinded uh study where the
the participants don't know
um you know sometimes they do it double
blind so that the the people are running
it don't know themselves
and
um you do a number of this you get a
whole bunch of people to to talk to on a
uh a number of different things and they
they say you think this is a human or
not human or not humor or not until this
Point
um the only things that actually pass
the Turing tests were uh
chat programs that would pretend to be
like a nine-year-old kid
they're already handicapping it right
right
um but that that was a couple years ago
this is before like the the current
large language models and the large
language models do much better you can
still Trip them up but they can have
what can be surprisingly intelligent or
at least seemingly intelligent
conversations with the individual or
without giving away that they're huge
they're not human okay
um so
um the to pass the Turing test is to
just have a greater than 50 of the
people that interact with it thinking
it's a human
because let's say they're like you know
on average you know you're you're going
to be talking to half humans half
computers you don't know which one is
which and you're trying to fool more
than half the people to think that
you're a human versus not
I suppose you could introduce all sorts
of wrinkles right like you could have
human beings that are kind of ringers
you know uh or you could have like
multiple different AIS mixed in there
like some with really good capacities
and some who are going to get outed as
computers relatively early you know yeah
we could imagine all sorts of
interesting permutations on this right
on but once again he
he cares about behavior and not actual
intelligence yeah can can you simulate
the behavior of an intelligent person
versus not so this also kind of comes
back to the um
what is that the we talked about it the
other day many a year or two ago the the
Chinese room oh this is John swirls yeah
uh thought yeah that's right yeah where
they're like you're passing notes
between things and you know if someone
can actually translate or they're I'll
just happen to have like all the the guy
that will give you yeah right
um and so
um once again these large language
models don't have to be perfect or even
intelligent in the way that we use it
like well actually conscious or sapiens
to be either useful or dangerous this is
a good uh segue then into some of the
things that
people have been reporting about these
so
um we played around with chat GPT a bit
and I I asked it and we're not going to
like do too much of this but I asked it
first what can you tell me about the
wisdom for Life show
and its response was pretty generic I've
gotten this response before I'm sorry
but as an AI language model so it's
funny because it's programmed to speak
of itself in the first person right
um and we we then attribute oh it's it's
talking to me it's it's like you know
relating to me I don't have access to
current or real-time information about
specific radio shows or events however I
can tell you there are many radio shows
and podcasts that focus on providing
advice tips and insights on various
aspects of life such as personal growth
relationships health and wellness Career
Development and more you may want to
search online for more information about
the wisdom for Life radio show or other
similar programs that may be of interest
to you so it's a big long verbiage about
I can't help you at all you know but
here's some generic stuff that I learned
about podcasts and it did you know like
tune in on the wisdom for life right so
right and then I so I thought well I'll
push it a bit more and and and sometimes
you can get it to give you interesting
answers you can say yeah okay I get you
that your data set doesn't include this
can you speculate can you imagine can
you go beyond what you gave me before so
I said
what would you imagine the wisdom for
Life radio show would be like what kind
of topics would they cover and the
answer is actually pretty decent based
on the name wisdom for life I would
imagine the radio show would focus on
providing listeners with practical
advice we say that every time right
that's that's there in the title
insights and wisdoms for various aspects
of Life the show May cover a wide range
of topics related to personal growth
relationships health and wellness career
development financial management
spirituality and more the show might
feature interviews with experts in
different fields who can share their
knowledge and experiences with the
audience it could also include segments
where listeners can call in or email
with their questions the holster guests
can provide guidance and advice overall
the show's goal would likely to be to
provide listeners with actionable
insights and strategies they can apply
to their own lives to help them live
happier healthier and more fulfilling
wise now if this was like a publicist
a human publicist we'd say okay that's
not great copy uh it's pretty generic
it's kind of just all over the map but
it's it's believable right and you know
there's some places where if we were a
bit more gullible we could be like holy
crap
that maybe this actually does know about
the wisdom for Life show I mean we do
give practical advice about how to live
your life better you know and wouldn't
it be good to have a call-in sort of
thing which you know obviously we can't
we can't do with this but it would be
kind of fun wouldn't it so
um I I could see this being the perfect
for a uh politicians press secretary oh
yeah yes I'm gonna give you an answer
but it's so generic and has no substance
to it that you can't say anything about
it at all
so that raises an interesting other
issue that we're going to get into in a
bit like how how these large language
models will make stuff up or screw up in
different ways right if if you had a
politician I mean politics is very
adversarial so if you screw up people
are going to pounce on it
you would need like a human overseeing
this wouldn't you if you're going to try
to have uh I don't know any of these
large language model AIS as your
replacement
yeah and so like that's actually one of
the main things that people are already
using for is like generate ideas it's
like yeah you're stuck on a thing I just
I need something to throw against the
wall and see if anything can just
click
um not that you're gonna use the copy
that it's done but like hey you know
give give me three ideas for an article
on yeah yeah
uh spaghetti and AI I don't know that's
you know that's really interesting to
think about because we typically call
that brainstorming right and we often
think of brainstorming as a particularly
not rule bound
um creative open activity you know no
wrong answers and you know we we invite
people to just like let loose
and
if it turns out that these large
language models are decent at doing that
in a sort of Brute Force way like you
said give me a hundred different
strategies don't give me three give me a
hundred that I can pick and choose from
um or just you know it doesn't even have
to be the only thing it's like just have
it as a another
um voice in the room you know okay yeah
yeah you you have a brainstorm and you
just like oh then there's there's some
topics that you know no wrong answers
right if it all can just jog maybe some
other good idea then it's not a
hindrance and it's not like
potentially even taking anything away
from anyone yeah although in a certain
sense we could say that because it's
been trained on all these let's call
them human artifacts it's really drawing
upon that this is one of the big
complaints that people are making when
it comes to visual AI that it's using
all of these artists work as reference
points without acknowledging any of them
and it's not doing anything that's
genuinely creative it's it's doing
something that's
pseudo-creative you could say right okay
yeah
um that I also they don't like how it
you know hands turn out looking
yeah right
um I I I've seen some really good
artists incorporate some of the uh image
models
um into their interests like they'll do
their work and then like well they just
want a generic background or something
and so they it's like hey give me like a
library and it would start out a library
and then they would go and like edit the
library to their specifications like
they wanted it change the sound the
other thing and
um it might be a way for artists to work
on the things that the thing are
actually the most important and thus
save you time of the things that are
less important background stuff but it
still makes the whole composition better
um yeah but I guess to to a certain
extent it's not like it's
it's not copying pixel for Pixel right
on right and it and to a certain extent
you can say that it does a very similar
process to by which artists learn how to
produce their own arch you go to uh
school and you learn how to copy the
Masters before you then create your own
style yeah and you spend time going to
the museum and doing those block things
you know and recreating them there yeah
um
there's definitely going to be a an area
in which
um certain jobs are going to be lost
there's going to be jobs lost in many
areas due to this and the question is
are we going to maintain a system in
which
um you know fewer and fewer people have
the ability to actually
um produce things or are you going to uh
spread the wealth and benefit of these
new technologies around people so that
we can all actually benefit in their
creation I mean I imagine it'll be
somewhere in between it can't it can't
fit the dystopian or utopian pole all
that closely coming back to something
though before we we uh jump into like
these larger scale speculations about
what it's going to do to our our society
so I I did ask it what it could tell me
about you Dan and when I did it it
couldn't tell me anything even though I
tried prompting the chat gpt3 in a whole
bunch of different ways the best I could
get uh was from asking who is Dan Hayes
host of the wisdom for Life radio show
and podcast and I did get a response but
it was conflated with it with another
Dan Hayes now you said that you got it
to actually tell you some useful things
about you right
right it
anything that it said that was useful or
correct about me was I believe
um
derived from similar that's oh he uh
follows her he's the host of a podcast
or radio show that's called wisdom for
life and so he it told me quote
um you know uh Dan Hayes is an American
Author speaker and radio show host he is
the host of Winston for Life radio show
and podcast where he interviews experts
on topics related to personal growth
spirituality and self-improvement that
sounds pretty good so yeah like we don't
interview too often but sometimes
absolutely yeah and then and then it
goes on to Haze is also the author of
several books including the seven
secrets of Life of meaning and finding
your purpose a guide to personal
fulfillment and so like I've not written
either of these books um and they're
even not a name or they are not written
by another person named Dan Hayes so
it's just pulling stuff out of its butt
at this point yeah and so that is a
common problem when when I asked that
about myself I actually wrote a whole
blog post about this that will will link
to in the show notes
um I got a real mixed bag of stuff and
it it told me that I had written
um very important papers and books about
say so system or you know German
idealism some of which were actually
written by people who I I know
colleagues of mine who I'm friends with
and so like for example Massimo
pigliucci wrote you know how to be a
stoic and when I queried it about me and
stoicism it attributed that book
verbatim to me so clearly there's some
some interesting errors going on but
some of the other people noted weirder
wackier stuff so one of my uh colleagues
Helen de Cruz who's very active on the
internet in public philosophy and has
written quite a few articles and books
She Wrote
if you are an academic it's interesting
to test chat GPT with please give me a
list with some of my Publications it
will make up the most hilarious
non-existing list and it makes me wonder
why this task isn't easier for an llm
why why it can't get them right
Kenny Pierce asked it about himself who
is the philosopher Kenneth L Pierce and
it attributed to him a bunch of real
Publications none of which are his and a
list of journals none of which he'd
actually published in but at least it's
sticking to real stuff in that case and
then Brian Norden who if you know if you
don't know who he is he is like really
famous for his uh work on Chinese
philosophy teaches at Vassar he's very
active on on the internet he said a
former student of his asked for a copy
of a non-existent publication he wrote
to him and said can I have this this
publication
that chat GPT had told them about so
what we're seeing here are some like
real world bleeding over right it's
producing pragmatic uh responses on the
parts of humans who
you know now these are academics who
should know pretty well what's real and
what's not when it comes to scholarship
but what do we do with students who are
like hey uh give me you know I've got a
paper due tomorrow night can you give me
like five sources on I don't know a
Renee Descartes and then Chachi PT just
makes them up you know right and then
they incorporate them into their paper
and then people it's almost you know we
we have like um literature like this
like if you think about Jorge Louis
borjes's famous story uh tlon ukbar
orbius tertius where uh a fictional
encyclopedia is created and it starts
bleeding over into the real world and
altering the real world I think we were
at risk for chat GPT or other things
being you know whatever others are gonna
replace it
for gullible people uh thinking that
those things are real but you know in a
way
maybe that's not so different I mean we
have people who watch soap operas and
then go to the grocery store and see the
actor and attack them because they don't
like them you know uh we've had all
sorts of things that have come out of uh
you know science fiction shows that we
talk about in our ordinary parlance so I
don't know I'm not convinced that this
is a grave danger but it is it is an
interesting feature that it it produces
fake stuff right so the the issue here
or one of the issues is that you know we
can't
um make inferences about all large a
large language models
um based off a type of GPT is just one
of them it just happens to be the most
well known yeah um and the other really
large problem is how you do we like to
find knowledge and truth especially
nowadays where knowledge and Truth are
are very contentious things for many
people yeah and so
um you know there are certain things
that are more easy to verify and they're
they're
um needs to be work done on these models
that um you know has more on
some sort of waiting system for being
able to verify these things are actually
true
um I'm not quite sure excuse me how you
do that but this is uh an issue that
needs to be gone for because of these
issues that are continually happening
and if you're going to be integrating
these things directly into Bing as Chad
GPT is currently yeah and you're going
to ask that you know you might not even
think know that it's a large language
model that you're asking
um you pose a question and it comes back
with information that is you know either
potentially incorrect or potentially
even harmful especially if you're asking
things like medical right so for you to
or for financial advice right absolutely
like anything that's going to be
potentially very detrimental to your
health and well-being at least in a
physical manner
um as well as mental on like I've heard
stories about giving it um
uh suicidal people really bad advice
and so um these are are all things that
we need to be aware of and you know
we're only at the infancy of this
technology and there are no guard rails
yeah yeah
um or the guardrail is a very familiar
or small so like for example if you
asked chap GPT to out to make up fake
stories about real people it says I
can't do that you can get right around
that I mean I this kind of leads to
another issue so would you need
something like so we've got and let's
say we're sticking with chat GPT right
so we've got this large language model
would you need something like a
secondary artificial intelligence above
it
that could
um
you know super Vein on it and say no no
don't do this or anymore but who watches
The Watcher well I mean
that that is a significant issue right
but it's a problem we're going to have
with human beings as well but this is
actually the key isn't to like have you
know it perfectly super being on it but
at least like root out 90 of the crazy
crap you know right and so this is
actually another thing in on AI and
machine learning is what we call
adversarial networks and so you train a
network and then you train another
Network to try to break the first
Network and whenever you break the first
Network it then uses that information to
shore up the places in which the first
Network breaks and so if you had a
another Network that was only about
trying to get purely fractional
information out and doesn't care about
like
um you know being able to actually
create a language that is uh human
readable
um but it says like that's wrong that's
wrong that's wrong and just keeps on
hitting it every time that's getting
wrong that can be a useful way of
potentially solving that issue
so you're retraining the AI
with another and they're they're
constantly reaching training to our GPT
they come out with new versions of it
yeah because they're they they get to a
point of like training and they say okay
this is good enough for publication at
the moment and then they're constantly
in the background retraining that model
adding more information yeah yeah
defining the uh edges the weights
but I mean
how how do we get the whatever system
we're working with
to let's let's use a slogan here take
truth seriously like be concerned in
some way about actually getting things
right because I actually played with it
uh with a different thing I started
asking I wanted to see what it could
tell me about the history of heavy metal
in the 1970s like who are they the
important groups and why all right and I
would ask it for like a list of 10 and
it would sometimes give me some that
weren't in there and I'd say well this
is from the 1980s this is from the 1980s
this is from the 1980s not the 1970s and
I would say oh I'm so sorry you know let
me give you a different list and then it
would like give some new ones that were
equally wrong or it would say it was
going to give me a list of nine or ten
and then it would give me nine you know
and you would think okay so I know we
human beings we we do a lot of screwing
up in that way too right we say oh yeah
I'll um I'll see you at two o'clock you
know when we show up at five or
something like that or you know we get
our files all messed up but we can at
least recognize when we screw up and
it's interesting because there's
something in the the program that
responds to me or any other person
saying you didn't get this right and it
it there's something that says yes yes I
didn't get this right let me try this
again you know and it even apologizes
but it does so in a way that makes you
think that no it doesn't it doesn't
really have there there's no like
conception there of getting things wrong
there's just some responses that are
baked into it I mean what do you think
about that is am I off base with that or
so many trap models
have taken the input of the users yeah
as new information to train the models
okay the chat Bots
the problem with this is lots of people
would go in and start spamming
incredibly you know vile things right
and then the the prime instance of that
right for view listeners who might not
know about that
yeah um this happens quite a number of
times
um do you remember the name of the the
one that was um just terrible like it it
started like you know being a pro-nazi
in all sorts of weird stuff yeah it
didn't take long either
um was it was it a Microsoft one that
did that yeah
um
but
there there are two two places where
there's often issues with what we call
garbage and garbage out okay
um the first thing is many of these
models are
built on text that has been scraped from
the internet
um and this includes you know all sorts
of nice places like encyclopedia or
sorry the Wikipedia Encyclopedia
Britannica New York Times you know all
your your major like Publications yeah
that are have at least some set of
journalistic Integrity
um but also uh things that are in like
the public domain such as
um all of the emails that were at Enron
because all the emails that Enron got
entered into evidence now they are
public usage and that became an
incredibly large portion of many of
these because it's all sorts of regular
human interactions with each other in
the business place but there is also
lots of really weird stuff that was
going on at Enron both you know
ethically from the uh you know
power distribution but also all sorts of
infidelity and all sorts of like if you
go through that there's a lot of kind of
like iffy stuff right you don't like
scrub that out then that becomes part of
your base model
um as well as you know the other
portions of it is the the portions of
the internet that are less Savory you
know there's portions of Reddit and
4chan and whatnot that are just
can have some very vile things in them
and so
that that once again garbage in garbage
out
well you know one of the things that I
do
I won't say a substantive amount of work
on but someone is is trying to debunk
fake quotes you know about famous
philosophers
and I've done uh three videos so far on
like the most egregious Plato and
Aristotle and Marcus Aurelius quotes and
uh a colleague of mine Phil yanov who
was using Bard he asked it to give him
quotes from Seneca about friendship and
he got a whole bunch of quotes and not a
single one of them were actually from
Seneca although they were being
attributed to it one of them was
actually from Marion Zimmer Bradley's
dark over
um you know speculative fiction series
and so you know he was kind of on the
alert and he's like since none of these
seem like actual quotes from Seneca I
asked Bard to give me the sources and
here's where another problem came up it
gave me letters so Seneca did write
letters right so it gave me letters and
paragraphs for each of them every single
one of them was erroneous everyone was
made up so he asked Bard to show him the
drafts that it considered and for each
of the quotes it showed a different
letter or paragraph number in each of
the drafts it was making them up but you
know they sounded good he said it but
they fabricated without reference and
then one of his takes from this
I'd like to see what you think about
this these llms are like one's kids they
know how to form sentences but they
don't always know the right answer so
they just give you something that sounds
right to them and then he says my fear
so it's more of a human fear uh or what
I fear about what humans are going to do
is that people might consider these
answers correct or even authoritative
and then signal boost them on social
media now we already have a huge huge
problem with fake quotes you know people
you know posting them on all of these
websites even things that should be kind
of reliable like the daily stoic will
every once in a while post something
that's clearly not by Marcus Aurelius or
Seneca or Epictetus and then they get
called on it and usually they take it
down and there's entire other sites that
just all they do is churn this sort of
stuff out right and so if that's part of
the
the data that the llms are being trained
on no wonder they're like you know adult
about like who said what right how the
hell are they going to figure it out
when you know we we people who actually
read the text are fighting a always rear
guard battle against human generated
fake quotes out there on the internet
attributed to famous people you know it
seems I mean it seems like it's it's not
a radically new problem but it's going
to become more
difficult
to root out and call call attention to
these you know fake quotes with ai's
um mixing them up we could say
it's always a
you know it's going to be an iterative
back and forth process you know and yeah
you know as with you know children
growing up in a parents teaching them
well and better over time this is one of
the things that some AI ethicists talk
about is okay at some point in time
there's a good chance that we will
actually create a uh Sapient AI
and at that point in time
is the ethics that we have and because
it's going to inherit the ethics that we
currently have and which are a mess oh
absolutely and so what what can we do in
order to potentially
guard against uh an AI that if it hits
the level of you know Singularity where
it starts to be able to grow faster and
faster than any of our own intelligences
um does it have the ethical grounding
um that it needs to make sure that it it
sees us as a beneficial contributor to
it and not as
uh something that is an hindrance to it
well maybe it can separate out the good
people from the bad people then
what a heroist you're going to use for
that
yeah and that's it that seems
problematic uh right who are the good
people also it came to my mind the other
when we were talking about truth it's
like okay if there's some sort of model
that's trying to determine truth
I want to know
what it's going to determine like these
hard questions of you know plagued you
know both philosophy and theology for
thousands of years like what is the
meaning of a good life you know what is
yeah the you know the truth about the
university ontologically is there are
Supernatural if there is which religion
correctly represents that particular
Supernatural
yeah I mean I don't think that there
there's going to be any progress on
those things about nature and
supernature and the Divine I mean ethics
is already going to be difficult right
um
oh go ahead I and I'm not saying that's
going to to make accurate
representations of it but it might come
up with a thing that it determines is
true oh is the right depending on how
how much it has power over ourselves in
society that could have really
interesting effects on you know outcomes
you know
um the issue of Truth which we talked
about in several different shows a while
back and what we'll put links to that as
well
um it's it's it's a really complicated
one there's no one single conception of
truth that adequately captures what we
human beings mean by true you know
oftentimes in philosophy when we're
doing intro classes we'll say well you
got the correspondence theory and the
coherence Theory and the pragmat and the
pragmatist Theory but we actually have a
whole bunch of other perspectives on
truth and they all kind of interfuse
together in complicated ways so yeah
getting getting an AI to wrap its
metaphorical head around that when we
human beings already have a hard time
making sense of that anyway
um it seems like a pretty daunting
Prospect doesn't it
absolutely and so it's both
you know
potentially scary as well as
exhilarating to see you know what new
things might happen so this kind of
reminds me of I don't know who quoted
this but like
um any technology that happens before
you're 30
is exciting and new and potentially for
something to get into you anything that
any new technology that happens after
you're 30 is scary and might break the
things that you use to survive currently
see I don't really buy that
um being somebody who's who's lived
through all sorts of technological
shifts you know as a gen xer I can see
that like I have some people who are my
age who they may as well be 80 you know
and like
um deciding that they're you know those
kids these days they're on their way out
and then there's others who you know are
like on The Cutting Edge or help form
The Cutting Edge still today and it's
it's hard to generalize it is
interesting though there was this big
discourse back in educational theory and
this is like the early 2000s where the
Boomers who were the ones in charge of
everything at that time were telling all
of us younger Gen X professors you've
got to watch out because these young
kids coming up your your generation they
are the digital Natives and and you know
they know all about this technology from
you know just imbibing it from from
birth onward and you know we're like
what the hell are you talking about
these kids can't like figure out how to
save a file properly let alone how to
actually make use of their their phones
or uh tablets and stuff like that every
single generation has to be like
retrained and there's all sorts of
things that have it dropped out of the
picture like oh yeah we we know what a
floppy disk looks like and we understand
that the little floppy disk icon up
there means save but you know if you
never had any of that sort of Technology
around you're like what you know that
weird little icon that's that's what I
do to save things you know it's called
the skeuomorphism
what is that skeuomorphism where we use
uh icons of things that are no longer
around like there's there's a trash bin
on your computer right right yeah to for
your recycling and then there's like the
little save icon as a floppy disk
um there's I mean
yeah but there's a picture of a phone
handset oh for on for the phone function
on your phone that's true yeah
laughs
yeah so I suppose these these things
will eventually get replaced right or go
away or or they become so ritualized
that nobody knows what they where they
came from and we just stick with them
think of so many um you know uh terms of
phrases that's like I'm still like
learning where they come from I know
what they mean but I have no idea where
the reference that they were originally
referencing is totally outside of our
you know to be hoisted on one's own
patard
that's to be blown up by an explosive
that you've intended to explode on
someone else yeah it's okay it's funny
that you mentioned that one because my
you know my family being French Canadian
so patara is is a um word for explosive
right and it's also a word for small
fireworks as opposed to food artifice
which are the like the big fireworks
that you shoot off and but it's also an
it becomes an automata poetic uh thing
because
um I'd listen to my uncle like you know
light something and he'd say here goes
the Patel right and you know that's the
sound that it makes when it blows up
right for French people not for
English-speaking people you know for
English-speaking people it goes bang yes
um
so one of the things that is happening
though
is that many companies are getting rid
of their ethicists
um
over 400 people I believe at Google have
been fired but there's been uh Google
twitch and Microsoft are some large Tech
players that are using lots of
um AI they're just getting rid of their
ethicists because they're trying to put
guard rails on this because they're
seeing the writing on the wall and the
potential negative aspects that happened
to it and this is at odds with the
potential billions that can be made by
utilizing this technology and once again
the profit motive outweighs the ethical
motive
and you have these firings do you think
that part of it is also what you were
talking about this exhilaration it's
sort of like I don't want you to bother
me with all these ethical considerations
there's cool stuff that's happening or
or is it in your view primarily the
profit motive
it's really pregnant like
they were doing lots of cool stuff it
wasn't like they were saying like don't
do anything it's like we just need to be
careful about this thing but that
doesn't allow you to move fast and the
you know one of the big imperatives in
the tech industry is move fast and break
things
foreign
yeah that's true I've heard that model
many times do you think that's I mean
we're getting close to the end of the
hour so you can't say an awful lot about
that but do you think we're gonna ever
see a time where that's not like part of
the defining ethos of the tech world
technology
that is
to reproduce at home that can cause
potentially death and destruction then
that is the point this is the the
proverbial black ball technology whereas
like a nuclear power is a gray or
nuclear power or nuclear breaking the
atom is a gray ball it's incredibly
powerful but also incredibly dangerous
but it's also very very difficult to
produce okay and black ball is something
that is potentially very powerful and
also very dangerous and is easy to
produce by one or fewer you know one or
small group of people
um if we create technology that is that
then there's going to be a real big sea
change because we're not just talking
about like potential wealth or something
that must be lost but this is like
changes of death okay
well I mean that makes a lot of sense
um anything else that we should say to
wrap up before you lead us out on the
final thought I think just like the our
final like recommendation of like a
practice to you know be aware of the
limitations of these things whenever you
are asking these models to um just take
it with a grain of salt okay
so uh you want to lead us out on a final
quote
um so we leave you the words of Dan
Simmons the basic ethical consideration
over the next 50 years will be I believe
do we encourage the creation of such out
of control networks of billions of happy
simple minded embedded thinking devices
or do we somehow attempt to control them
[Music]
foreign